j'accueille dont brice hortefeux merci
beaucoup de nous rejoindre brice
hortefeux député européen membre des
républicains on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par stéphane bern
et qui dirige le bureau parisien de
ouest france moulin stéphane bonjour je
trouve à parler bien sûr de la
présidentielle on en parlait il ya
quelques instants avec etienne blond
mais d'abord la crise sanitaire et un
premier cas de variants omnikron a donc
été détectée sur le territoire français
à la réunion est ce que vous dites que
le gouvernement prend les mesures
suffisantes est ce que vous êtes
rassurés sur la gestion actuelle de la
crise sanitaire de la part du
gouvernement chez moi être rassurés mais
me malheureusement s'il ya une phrase un
écrivain auvergnat peut le manger lisez
nos actes nous suivent
je suis un peu inquiet parce que en
était la crise sanitaire que nous avons
vécu en bas de celle qui plaît
susceptible d'arriver et a été synonyme
un peu de pagaille à de retard on a été
retardée quasiment surtout on a été
atteint sur les maskoutains sur les
tests retard sur les vaccinations et
d'ailleurs ou pic de la pandémie
vous avez plusieurs organismes tant le
site bloomberg qui nous a placés 48e sur
53 pays pour la gestion de cette crise
sanitaire donc c'est un peu préoccupant
maintenant pour l'avenir j'espère que
les leçons ont été tirées vous en doutez
comme tous les français comme tous les
français je suis préoccupé je suis
inquiet je m'interroge d'autant plus que
la communauté scientifique
si on veut la suivre c'est plus
compliqué que l'interprétation des
pythie de delphes puisque on a vraiment
toutes les toutes les phrases tous les
maux ils disent une chose et son
contraire il faut s'inquiéter mais
finalement non peut-être que oui on
verra enfin prêt qu'est ce que vous
propose rien qu'est ce que vous
préconisez aurier à l'exécutif
aujourd'hui par rapport à la crise qui
avait fermé les frontières par exemple
d'un d'abord tenir le langage de vérité
et dire s'ils ne savent pas qu'ils le
disent aujourd'hui on ne dit rien on dit
c'est inquiétant mais en même temps on
fait passer le message le certains
propos de l' oms laisse entendre que
finalement ces variants serait peut-être
certes contagieux mais peut-être moins
graves dont on entend tout et son
contraire donc dire la vérité
c'est-à-dire dire très exactement ce que
l'on sait et surtout à ce stade ce que
l'on ne sait pas deuxièmement je pense
que la fermeture des frontières est un
élément constitutif de la protection ça
naturellement il n'y a pas une solution
il n'y a pas une initiative miracle si
ça existait ça se saurait mais ça fait
partie des gens qui sont là il faut
l'envisager et troisième élément il faut
bien sûr poursuivre la politique
vaccinale
parce que nous ne sommes pas les mieux
placés sur le continent européen on a
encore un nombre important plusieurs
villes ont comme vous savez de personnes
qui ne sont pas toujours pas vaccinées
donc il faut intensifier l'effort
pédagogique
gouvernement
méthodes
dont les mouiller
dans les faits non
pourquoi le ministre de l'outre-mer à
juste titre
rappelle que la loi de la république
s'appliquent partout
qui n'entend pas qu'ils aient de recul
que ne peut pas y avoir de discussions
sans un préalable préalable la
condamnation des agressions à balles
réelles ce qui est quand même incroyable
contre les forces de l'ordre et puis
dans les faits il se passe pas grand
chose alors il ya des sujets pour lequel
il faut faire un effort de pédagogie
je pense au chlordécone qui est un sujet
extrêmement sensible extrêmement
sensibles notamment en martinique où les
u11 sentiment qu'ils étaient en partie
exact et qu' il y avait un traitement
différent de la mer entre la métropole
il territoire ce avec le col cour
d'école a été interdite lüthi son
utilisation c'est le chlordécone c'est
dans ce produit qui permet de lutter
contre les chansons qui était absolument
indispensable pour protéger certaines
productions mais il s'est avéré toxiques
notamment il a des conséquences sur le
cancer de la prostate et sur le
territoire vous avez deux fois plus a
pas rapporté à la population de cancer
de la prostate qui mit en existe comme
on en recense en métropole 1 donc il
faut que hier comme attire les choses
dire oui et c'est vrai il ya eu une
erreur qui a été commise la métropole a
interdit l'utilisation de ce produit
trois ans avant que ça soit interdite
outre-mer il ya une deuxième vérité est
que je m'entends pas beaucoup c'est que
on dénonce à juste titre les
interruptions par exemple de l'eau
potable afin l'eau c'est une compétence
des collectivités c'est pas une histoire
d'autonomie jazz est là c'est de la
compétence des collectivités alors
l'état aide contrairement à ce que ce
qui est diffusé sur place on se tourner
vers l'état pour dire qu'est ce que
c'est non c'est les collectivités qui
ont la responsabilité de la gestion de
l'eau et l'état qui au contraire a aidés
à protéger donc il ya un certain nombre
de choses à faire
dans les mobiles est fait non c'est à
dire que pour reprendre les choses
sébastien lecornu gouvernement n'ont pas
eu raison de prolonger l'obligation
vaccinale jusqu'au 31 décembre il
fallait tenir comme en métropole où il
fallait s'adapter compte tenu de la
situation c'est une situation
extrêmement
explosive et en partie irrationnel en
partie rationnelle c'est la méfiance
vis-à-vis la politique vaccinale heureux
et en partie rationnelle et puis il ya
une partie qui au contraire est
totalement rationnelle c'est les
difficultés économiques du territoire
mais vous savez
oui mais avec des contreparties niveau
peu décalé de quelques jours mais à quoi
sion qui est des engagements condition
qu'ils aient des ddd proposition de
reprise de l'activité de fin des
blocages
d'apaisement l'ail et ça donne le
sentiment qui est un mauvais sentiment à
l'égard de toute la population je dirais
loyalistes même si c'est pas le mot qui
s'applique pour ces territoires de
l'outre-mer cette partie de loot revient
mais ce sont des signaux qui sont des
signes de recul donc il y à une première
chose à faire il ya une première chose à
faire c'est la pédagogie une deuxième
chose à faire c'est que le ministre soit
effectivement sur place et il y est allé
mais sans doute un peu tard et troisième
chose à faire c'est sans doute mettre
autour de la table pour l'ensemble des
partis mais qui ne sut en leur rappelant
qu'elles ne doivent pas se défausser sur
l'état et qu'elles doivent assumer leurs
responsables le patio collectivités
locales
les négociations ont tourné court
puisque vous le disiez les syndicalistes
refuse de condamner les violences envers
les policiers les gendarmes sébastien
lecornu refuse de négocier dans ces
conditions vous auriez fait de même il a
raison de refuser de négocier en ces
cautions parce que la population ne veut
ni trompez pas la population l'amande
immense majorité la population n'est pas
sur cette ligne de violence et
d'ailleurs pour la martinique que je
connais un peu mieux que la guadeloupe
et si vous mettez la question statutaire
des denrées étaient les indépendantistes
on les entend hors campagne électorale
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
en métropole pendant les campagnes
électorales n'entend quasiment pas parce
qu'ils savent très bien que c'est
impopulaire et pourquoi c'est
impopulaire parce que vous avez toute
une série d'îles autour qui sont des
îles qui ne sont pas encore qu'ils aient
une influence française mais qui vous
avez 5 lui si vous avez antigua vous
avez toutes les délits qui sont très
agréables comme sonorités pour nous
métropolitain et dans lesquels les
conditions sociales des conditions
protection de ceux de santé sont
absolument pas les mêmes absolument
c'est la raison pour laquelle sébastien
lecornu mais la question de l'autonomie
sur la table est-ce qu'il a raison de
faire ça ou est ce qu'il est en train
d'ouvrir la boîte de pandore à votre
avis mais je pense que c'était dangereux
je pense que c'est dangereux d'ouvrir
cela d'ailleurs j'ai remarqué que le
gouvernement a fait un va et vient sur
ce sujet puisqu'il a avancé ça comme une
solution et maintenant on change
totalement de pied et on explique que
c'est laid que localement qu'on l'a
demandé vous le voyez que là il ya d'une
valse hésitation qui n'est pas
rassurante rien juste pour terminer là
dessus d'ouvrir la boîte de pandore
comme le dit stéphane on entend déjà du
côté de la corse des questions se pose
est est-ce que ça justifie un peu le
fait qu'il faut de la violence pour que
ces questions soient ouvertes mais
justement c'est un défaut d'anticipation
la démonstration on a attendu
terriblement attendu trop attendu et
c'est abouti à ces violences
inadmissibles l'autre sujet
l'intérieur ont trouvé la mort au large
de calais mercredi est ce que ce drame
pour vous était évitable et si oui
comment
c'est naturellement un sujet extrêmement
extrêmement compliqué donc ça peut pas
se ce résumé d'une phrase de formule 1
selon gang qu'elle est quelle est la
réalité c'est que vous avez
effectivement des tentatives de passage
les chiffres d'ailleurs sont est
difficile à cerner va vous avez ma
chiffre qui donne à mon avis une bonne
compréhension de ce qui se passe c'est
que il y a eu quinze mille peu plus de
15000 tentative de franchissement depuis
le 1er janvier et c'était de l'ordre de
6 ans en 2018 vous voyez une explosion
d'autres cas d'autres méthodes d'autres
qui sont pris à des chiffres plus
importantes en un peu plus de 30000 mais
en tout cas je donne le chiffre parce
qu'ils montrent l'évolution de la
gravité deuxième élément sur ceux qui
tentent de franchie en face sur cette
population qui arrive sur cette partie
du territoire français vous en avez 60 %
qui seraient éligibles au droit d'asile
selon nos nos règles et en réalité il
n'ya que 5 % qui souhaitent en
bénéficier
ça veut dire qu'ils veulent partir et
vaille que vaille coûte que coûte que en
angleterre troisième élément on fait
référence aux aînés aux accords dits du
touquet qui sont entrées en vigueur en
février 2004 c'était un accord qui
étaient très intelligents et très utile
mais qui ne correspond ne traitait que
de l'immigration légale et qui avait eu
vent était une surveillance simplement
de l'axé par le tunnel sous la mer et
par les ferries là on parle d'autre
chose on parle de l'immigration illégale
et quatrième élément est un élément je
termine juste quatrième élément qui est
un élément essentiel c'est que depuis
ces accords eh bien il ya le bre site
qu'est ce que ça signifie le break site
ça veut dire que la frontière de
l'europe s'est déplacée elle n'est plus
nenê plus en angleterre elle est sur les
côtes françaises sur ces accords du
touquet il faut les revoir ou pas hier
gérald darmanin dit pas de remise en
cause des accords du tout cas la raison
mais est ce sont deux choses dont on
parle mais on essaie de mélanger tout
dans les accords du touquet c'était pour
gérer la migration légale là aujourd'hui
on a changé totalement de dispositif
alors est ce qu'il ya une solution
miracle bien sûr qu'il n'y en a pas il
n'y a pas une solution il ya une palette
de solutions qu'elles sont quels sont
les éléments de ces palettes de cette
palette ont naturellement il ya une
surveillance française naturellement et
à la politique britannique qui est
aujourd'hui une politique très étonnant
parce que d'un côté il refuse
d'accueillir ces migrants mais d'autre
part ils ont une législation sociale
notamment qui fait que les migrants
souhaitent se rendre sur pattes parce
qu'ils sont assurés plus facilement de
trouver du travail d'être recrutés ainsi
tweeté à sans compter naturellement la
communauté linguistique qui ce qui est à
1 des cas l'explication du coup général
l'armée n'en dit pas de remise en cause
certains qu'on
négocie bertrand il faut les dénoncer on
fait quoi xavier bertrand lui propose de
donner un ticket ferry puis qu'ils
aillent la barre dont naturellement
c'est pendant jay sean sur ce point je
ne partage pas l'analyse de xavier
bertrand parce que l'expérience que j'ai
dans ce domaine j'ai été effectivement
mises sur l'immigration et milices de la
terre et l'immigration je sais une chose
c'est que quand on en trouve on fait un
appel d'air donc ce message serait reçue
comme un appel d'air vous savez et quand
il ya quelques années on avait
de régulariser un certain nombre de
personnes dans notre pays avec de
nouveaux critères ça avait fait un appel
d'air ça fait 80 mille migrants
supplémentaires donc que faut-il faire
en réalité c'est pas simplement à calais
que la question se pose c'est sur les
frontières de l'europe vous avez la
frontière pour schématiser vous avez
lampedusa en italie puis vous avez la
frontière gréco turque voilà je pensais
que c'est là qu'il faut arrêter il ya
géré à nantes il ya un aspect que vous
n'évoquez pas vous vous dites 600 pas
tentative de passage en 2018 15000
aujourd'hui on a une image
d'illustration qui montre une toute
petite embarcation avec un tout petit
groupe ce qu'on voit aussi aujourd'hui
ce sont d'énormes semi rigide avec des
motorisations de compétition des bateaux
qui coûtent des fortunes et en fait des
trafics qui se sont organisés sur notre
sol là on parle de mafia qui organise le
passage de ces migrants on sait où on
présente on pressent que les
organisateurs de cette mafia y sont en
grande bretagne est-ce que là il n'y a
pas quelque chose à négocier avec les
anglais de l'ordre judiciaire pour taper
sur ceux qui organisent ces passages qui
sont devenus industrielle en réalité
bien sûr mais vous avez partie en
losange allait le préciser mais vous
même lame avait précédé c'est que ces
trafics sont extrêmement lucratif on
sait quand ils gagnent des fortunes et
on peut légitimement penser que les
bénéficiaires de ces trafics sont en
bretagne
se peut se retrouver quasiment à la city
et avec des blanchiments d'argent
considérables donc ou dans les airs les
discussions que l'on doit avoir avec les
britanniques ça doit être un des
éléments bien sûr important mais vous
avez raison on est passé de la petite
frêle embarcation à une système qui est
beaucoup plus industrielles
dernière ligne droite c'est samedi on
connaîtra le candidat des républicains à
la présidentielle vous qui connaissez
bien les militants qui est sur le
terrain nous avons un pronostic non il
n'ya pas de jets pas de pronostic mais
j'ai surtout un constat à ce stade c'est
que
d'abord la vie publique s'organise
autour des républiques le président de
la république intervient comme par
hasard des lendemains d'un débat vous
avez quel comme saab vous avez un autre
candidat que vous avez vous venez
d'évoquer avec étienne blanc qui se cale
se cale où se calque sur notre le
calendrier
une provocation
j'y vois surtout la confirmation que les
républicains sont de retour que c'est
devienne le pivot
aujourd'hui de la vie publique de notre
pays puisque tout est calculé au tour de
calendrier qu'a voulu christian jacob
donc il ya plusieurs signaux qui sont à
adresser d'abord les républicains sont
en bonne santé
deuxième élément c'est eux qui
aujourd'hui avance non seulement des
constats mais aussi des propositions il
ya une diversité de propositions et
troisième élément on nous avait déclaré
moribond encore une fois je pense que
nous sommes en bien meilleure santé que
ce qui est déclaré qu'on était moribond
et quatrième élément et nous serons unis
nous allons avoir dans mon 24 heures un
peu moins d'1 4 heures maintenant 23h50
l'ouverture du scrutin pour le premier
tour il y aura ensuite un deuxième tour
et à l'issue de ce deuxième tour nous
serons rassemblés derrière le candidat
ou la candidate qui sera qui sera
choisie qui va gagner je vous parlais de
signaux vous avez des remontées du
terrain à votre avis qui va l'emporter
écoutez c'est ça qui est d'ailleurs
intéressant c'est que comme la campagne
était de bonne tenue c'est très décevant
pour les journées je suis désolé pour
vous parce que ça a été une période
compliquée parce que
les bas les débats étaient respectueux
il n'y a pas eu d'agression pas eu de
fausse polémique
ce que vous n'aimez pas mais bref tout
ce que vous n'aimez pas et mais c'était
deux jumeaux on parle beaucoup de fonds
dans cette émission on parle d'une
proposition des candidats
vous est de la même région michel
barnier pourquoi le choix de valérie
pécresse et passe une michelle s'est
d'abord mois dans la diversité des
candidats moi nous sommes de la même
famille donc moi je j'apprécie
j'ai apprécié eric ciotti
philippe juvin
michel barnier je respecte la démarche
xavier bertrand mais c'est vrai que je
me suis engagé
pour valérie pécresse eux parce que je
pense que c'est tout à la fois
un tempérament elle est très tenace
lâche rien elle va jusqu'au bout
et c'est en même temps une histoire
parce que
la
gagner une région face à salé ce qui
était à l'époque un des plus hauts
personnages de l'état sous françois
hollande quand elle a battu le président
de l'assemblée nationale claude
bartolone et en même temps elle était
très courageuse il s'agit pu l'observer
quand nous étions gouvernement ensemble
quand elle a engagé la réforme très
difficile d unicité sait combien le
monde étudiant est sensible il faut pas
grand chose un bon dieu pour allumer le
feu donc elle a très bien géré cela et
puis surtout je vous dirais que là un
projet qui était le projet très
construit peut-être le plus construit se
veut pas dire que les autres ceux ci
n'avaient pas de e même dit magique
imaginé un projet d'alternance mais en
tout cas j'ai trouvé que son projet
était très construit donc vous dire il
ya des fois tu nas coriace efficace et
donc c'est pour ça que je me suis engagé
à ses côtés samedi vous aurez votre
candidat est qu'il faut démarrer la
campagne tout de suite ou alors ce que
c'est pas là c'est pas le bon moment il
ya les fêtes de noël qui arrive etc
c'est quoi votre conseil par rapport à
votre expérience je pense que il faut
adresser dans la foulée de cette
élection un signal d'unité et de
rassemblement
un grand meeting par exemple c'est ce
qu'envisage et christian jacob et
d'ailleurs je pense qu'on est nombreux
lui rendre hommage parce que il a remis
autour de la table tous ceux qu'il avait
quitté ou tous ceux qui voulaient la
renverse et c'est pas si facile quand on
est
je n'en sais rien parce que c'est une
tradition c'est en tout cas c'est ce qui
était envisagé
des milliers de personnes
c'est une décision de christian jacob
sur la base des éléments sanitaires que
vous aurez que nous aurons vous et nous
sur ce sujet mais je pense qu'il
faudrait
écouter il faut attendre pour l'instant
toute l'organisation est en place pour
adresser un signal fort d'unité de
rassemblement et de confiance il ya un
homme que vous connaissez bien c'est
laurent wauquiez qui officiellement est
neutre dans cette campagne il fait
candidat pour qui il fait campagne pour
kingdom et laurent wauquiez c'est c'est
très simple il ne s'en est pas engagé à
l'occasion de deux scrutins ils avaient
décidé d'ailleurs ce qui a déçu
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de ses amis
d'antan dans je fais partie il ne s'est
pas engagé lui-même peut être était ce
une décision difficile et sage
les deux
mais
non il fait campagne pour aucun des
candidats il a des relations très
cordiales avec un certain nombre d'entre
eux il a dit dès le départ qu'il
accueillerait tous ceux sans exceptions
pour être tout à fait clair ceux sans
exceptions qui souhaiteraient le voir et
le rencontrer il n'y avait aucune
difficulté mais je suis convaincu qu'il
était alors que notre candidat aura été
choisie aura été élu il s'engagera à ses
côtés pour le succès des
[Musique]
jeux je n'en sais rien mais en tout cas
ce que je souhaite c'est que il y ait
une alternance et une équipe pour
diriger notre pays pour mettre fin à la
pagaille que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui dans ce quinquennat raté la
majorité présidentielle s'est affiché
hier soir à la mutualité à paris en
lançant son sa maison commune sous le
vocable ensemble citoyens edouard
philippe était là est-ce que vous pensez
que la recomposition du paysage
politique notamment autour de la droite
elle est fait ou est ce que ça peut
encore bouger autrement dit ce que vous
pensez qu'il ya des grands élus chez
vous qui peuvent changer de camp dans
les jours qui viennent après notamment
le choix de votre candidat ou notre
candidate à la présidentielle coucher
tout c'est fini ça j'avais changé de
camp c'est même moi je sais pas ce que
ça veut dire très honnêtement en tout
cas c'est pas moi c'est pas mon
tempérament moi ce qu'encore une fois ce
que ce que je crois c'est qu'il faut
qu'on se rassemble pour mettre fin à l'
ce quinquennat qui aura été caractérisé
par la pagaille tout azimut de secondes
pagaille social avec eux c'est le
mouvement des gilet jaune qui
sporadiquement ressurgi depuis trois ans
pagaille sanitaires je viens de vous
donner quelques quelques éléments
pagaille migratoires on en a dit
indirectement un moment enfin je vous
rappelle que jamais notre pays n'a
compté autant d'étrangers sur d'autres
territoires à ce que la société
française est prête à quoi accepter cela
je ne le crois pas pagaille sécurité à
vous avez si vous regardez les données
qui sont les données officielles vous
avez une augmentation de 25% et des
rixes sur un an c'est pas c'est pas un
bon signal pagaille outre-mer pagaille
des finances publiques je rappelle
simplement et j'avais terminé mais sûr
mais encore je pourrais continuer une
liste de pagaille enfin sur nos finances
publiques on a aujourd'hui 56 % de notre
richesse qui est consacré à la dépense
publique s'est jamais vu dans notre
histoire jamais un tel niveau et ça ne
se voit nulle part ailleurs dans les
pays développés donc oui il ya une forme
de pagaille
[Musique]